the word for h-o-r in Hebrew where we
get our w-h-o-r-e word means Womb or
cave
and so ahor like
is a womb it's a cave it's sacred Place
caves have all like since time
immemorial been these wombs of the Earth
where we can go and return to the mother
where we can go and be in complete pitch
Blackness like when you go tour a cave
and they've got it all lit up it would
not be like that you would maybe have
one torch and good luck because the
deeper you get in there the less oxygen
there is and then like your fire is
going to go out eventually so caves were
this massive place of initiations and
rights and rituals we were singing in
the largest cave system in Europe that
was so powerful and so beautiful and so
for me I just feel as you know we
started with the word weird I am I'm a
Gemini I love words I love communicating
I really
feel deeply that so much of who Mary
Magdalene is or was in the Bible and how
she's represented in religion the same
as like how witches are represented when
the word means Wise It's like which is
where the doctors in every village
imagine if we treated doctors the way we
have treated witches like it's just
outrageous so I really got interested in
her because it appears to me like so
many other things in our modern society
she's just been misrepresented and she
was very likely the wife of Jesus and
his counterpart in charging and in
utilizing Sex Magic and creative energy
right they're the same energy the same
frequency we make love we make a baby
right it's creative Sexual Energy is
Creative Energy and so
you know I saw the little tidbit on
Tundra so I don't want to repeat
anything for anyone because you got
Kaya's podcast on that but there is so
much for me about the again the laying
on of hands these like ancient easy
simple magic just like putting my hands
upon someone and generating these
frequencies these waves this healing
this change of mind change of heart
and so I believe that her womb wisdom
and her work as this [__] this womb
Cave of the Earth where we can return
for initiations and for rights of
Passage and for transformation I believe
that she was very much like an awakened
Avatar the same as Jesus was and they
were working in in Union together
um in order to create these Miracles and
then she was just written out of of the
stories the same as like you know
there's so many different I mean we
could go into so many rabbit holes I
know you like Robin holes um but like
the the words in the Bible that have
been changed ruach the word that is used
now for the holy spirit means wind you
know it's the breath of life and we
change these words so much there was a
time there's a translation of the Bible
where if you go back far enough the word
that became
um
Witchcraft and like why witches are bad
and evil it was originally manipulation
so there's just like you know back then
before the printing press which was
invented in the 1500s we're talking
about the Bible being written you know
in like the early one two three hundreds
like these different versions everything
is transcribed by hand so whoever's
sitting there whoever's paying that
person to write this down can say change
this do that like I want this to be like
this and the Bible was just changed over
and over again depending that's why we
have like the King James version because
he was the leader at the time that that
version was being propagated and so I
believe that Mary Magdalene was you know
like a goddess of her time an
enlightened woman a powerful spiritual
being who was misrepresented and and
misunderstood and and was leading
rituals and and teaching and being
highly respected until you know it was
no longer safe for her to to be doing
that or until she died you know that
that part there's a lot of mystery
around what happened but for me because
of the gifts that I have always had
um because of my long study of Tantra
because of just like the nature of the
reality that I want to create and live
in it seemed like a very potent
experience to participate in and go to
these places where you know we even get
like it said that the lineage of the
cathars is
passed down from Mary Magdalene and we
even get the word catharsis or cathartic
from the cathars who were these people
these Mystic people that survived until
like the 1200s in in southern France and
in this this region where where I am now
and and so you know it feels to me like
there's just there's always just so much
Lost Wisdom and that's what obviously
you're doing too like in such a big
beautiful way and what were all those of
us who are on this path of sharing are
really here to just help first remember
within ourselves and go through those
agonizing moments and those miserable
times and those shitty [__] days
where you're just like I can't do this
anymore like I don't know what's
happening help me and
persevering and pushing through and
knowing that people like Mary Madison
and people like Jesus you know they
dealt with a lot of horrible [__] to to
hold those transmissions for people like
us to remember and then you know send
out and transmit into the world so it
just felt like a really important uh
piece of the puzzle for me as well and
and really because I do also notice for
me like something I've never shared on a
podcast before but um I really do notice
my witch wound which you know we can
talk more about everyone has it's like a
result of magical people and people in
their power being burned and wiped out
from the planet
all indigenous cultures and
civilizations throughout colonization
and and history
but a lot of that shows up for me in my
partnership and I feel afraid sometimes
to like show him the depth of my magic
and like he's the person that's closest
to me and he's there with me all the
time and you know just like little
things a wrong facial expression one
small sentence that he'll say or that he
said at the beginning of our
relationship like these things that will
just stick in my mind and create this
massive fear of like showing up
as yeah as like the queen and the
Priestess and so that was another big
piece of it for me was like I can't live
in this illusion anymore like I am a
Magdalene I am a holy horde like a wound
Cave of the earth designed for you know
transformation and rebirth and and the
most important place for me to bring
that is is into my life with my king
so that like that Ripple that I'm
sending out into the world is pristine
and it's pure and it's in full Integrity
so that was that was really the the
deeper reason for me going one of the
things that Kaya talked about was I
shared the story about reading the Isis
initiation
um and how cold I was that night and she
was like well that's just your body
remembering and processing you know
lifetimes of being murdered for your
magic there are so many of us that share
and feeling like there's more and that
there was that that we have this power
and it's just been suppressed and not
um encouraged or cultivated this is the
time to bring the magic back so
um so thank you yeah it really is
because and it's not a it's not an us or
them thing it's not a men or women or
anything like that it's more about how
do we do it all together because
actually this was said and talked about
in the interview yesterday it's about
talking about the energies of two people
coming together and when you get the
toroidal field moving actually he said
not even at the same time but you you
actually get them going opposite and
they meet in the middle and create even
more like a like a like a Vortex of its
in in and of itself there that can't be
possible until both
are able to fully Express practice and
express what they're capable of so let's
talk more about just kind of like the
cult of Isis and you know the lineage
from that and you know what you know
about that because I was just very
intrigued about sex magic and a
girlfriend had given me the Magdalene
manuscript and I love channeling and
there's channeling in it and so maybe
going into like what about the the the
Cults of the cult of Isis and these
Cults that existed in ancient Egypt and
and I'm sure in other places too
um and and what their mission was
I mean everywhere like really when you
go back far enough like every
civilization has these beautiful
powerful ancient cultural Magics but we
get the word cult or we get the word
culture from these Cults right like this
is how we created our culture and just
really briefly something I want to
mention you said you know it's not about
gender men or women the witch wound
affects men in a totally different way
because they were actually supposed to
protect those women who were burned so
like people really negate men from the
witch wound but like that is outrageous
because imagine if it was your sister or
your daughter or your wife who's being
stripped out of your house and put up on
a pyre or drowned or whatever it is like
and it was your job to take care of her
there is a massive witch wound and of
course like you know men also like
anyone who was practicing magic or
earth-based wisdom or using the medicine
of plants which was the only medicine we
had all right the modern day
um anyone would be killed but that's
just something really important to
acknowledge for any uh masculine
listeners and like women with with male
Partners is or anyone with male Partners
is like really to recognize that it
affects men and and also really good
point you can't I mean no crying no
feeling like all of that it's all it's
just been programmed into us all
differently oh thank you so with the the
Cults of Isis you know I personally I
love so deeply uh just the magic of
utilizing energy as technology right and
that's what Tantra really is is like
energetic Alchemy this Elemental Union
of like breath and sound and movement
through the body and the Sweet Waters
and the sweat and the tears and like all
of the elements that make up our bodies
and and wielding them for our desires
for our healing
and so from my understanding
you know when I went to Egypt and I know
you've been on a pilgrimage I saw you
went with some of my sisters a few years
ago
um I personally you know everything
that's like called a sarcophagus I'm
like oh this is a burial chamber I'm
like that is [__] ridiculous like
those are not burial Chambers there's
nobody being buried in there but there's
a lot of magical sound frequency
technology in there and there's a lot of
really cool perfectly
you know little Whispering moments and
so it feels to me and also you know when
you when you go there
and you learn about how much bigger the
Nile was during that oh yeah it went
right up to the temples exactly so
they're like using Hydro power right you
know they're using water they're using
energy they're using sound and one of
the things that I'm sure you guys went
to the O Syria on that place that it
just was discovered 85 years ago
underneath the sand and these giant
stones that are all perfectly aligned
just like pristinely cut the same as the
Great Pyramids and they're like 150 tons
which is like 300 000 pounds each and I
sat up against one of them
and I love to do this channeled Writing
Practice you said you love channeling so
how I love to channel is I just invoke
whatever the thing is whether it's the
goddess or the dragons or Mother Nature
or the stones in this case and I said I
call upon the stones of eoserion please
write to me through me anything I'm
meant to receive in this moment yeah and
I asked them how did you get
there and they said they learned to sing
our songs
they learned to sing with us and they
asked us to come and we agreed
and they showed me I didn't write this
part down but they like showed me this
image of people singing and chanting I
don't know if what else may have been
creating Sonic frequency but like
utilizing word and voice and and like
perhaps Words of Power I didn't I'm not
very like Claire audience so I didn't
hear anything I just like saw this
visual of it yeah and it was like the
stones separated themselves from the
mountains there wasn't anything being
cut they just like kind of like stepped
forward out of the mountains and then I
was seeing them like floating and they
were like hovering over the ground if
you like this clip and you want to hear
the whole episode click at the bottom of
your screen